Kyle kashaf was there that day at
parkland he's a survivor the shooting is
a high school student in Parkland he
says he was recently called in for
questioning by school officials for
daring to go to a gun range with his dad
Kyle joins us tonight so Kyle in a my
thank you for coming on am i misstating
that did what tell us what you did that
earned you a trip to visit with armed
authorities at your school what was your
crime wasn't even a trip it was an
interrogation it was it was a clear
attempt to intimidate me and they used
very very very harsh intimidation
tactics I mean at the end the day I went
shooting with my dad at a gun range I
mean I did everything peacefully um I
went shooting with my dad and I I did
absolutely nothing wrong I mean I posted
a video of me showing my admiration for
the Second Amendment and telling people
to educate themselves about the Second
Amendment because we can't trust our
government to defend ourselves so you
went to a gun range with your dad which
i think is still legal in this country
and you'd think that we would encourage
this because you learn gun safety and
how to handle a gun appropriately you
didn't misuse it you got called in and
interrogated what questions could they
have asked you what would be the
interrogation so I come into the office
okay this is it was all very very weird
I get sit down and the school resource
ever goes like this he says Kyle you're
taking five AP class which was a good
student why would you do something like
this and I was I was in shock and I was
like what do you mean he's like why'd
you do something like this and they came
in there with the notion that I had done
something wrong by going to a gun range
so I was like what do you mean he's like
well you tweeted out a video of you at a
range I said did you see the tweet he
said no I didn't see the tweet I don't I
don't do Twitter so like well then check
the tweet the tweet in itself was a
video of me shooting a fire I'm telling
people to educate themselves about the
Second Amendment
so we talked back and forth and then the
Broward Sheriff's Officer comes into the
room he comes into the room he sits he
sits right behind me very very very
close and then the interrogation truly
starts they go whose gun is it
who'd you shoot it with why'd you shoot
who'd you shoot it with isn't your gun
is your dad's gun when did you go and at
this entire town I was like did I do
anything wrong
I mean still America last time I checked
I can go to a gun range and shoot it
peacefully and then I said why did I do
anything wrong
and they said don't get snappy with me
and then I was like alright can I record
this and they said no and I mean in
reality they they did not allow you to
record the conversation why nope I
explicitly asked blah I asked the school
resource officer may I record this and
he said no yeah and you told them you
were clear that you were with your
father mm-hmm and that they were very
they tried to somewhat tell me or to
intimidate me to somehow in criminate my
father there was a real push they came
in there like knowingly is saying that I
was at fault for doing for exercising my
Second Amendment right at a gun range
and it comes down to this it comes down
to this why should why should I be
interrogated for peacefully going to a
gun range I asked him was like did I do
anything wrong he said no you're not a
threat so why are they calling down me
why are they calling down me is this is
every single individual going to a gun
range gonna be called down what is the
end to it because it's a clear it's it's
a clear road to tyranny well maybe
because I have children I sympathize
with your father he's an adult American
citizen correct yeah I mean he has a
right to make his son where he wants
within the bounds of the law without
getting second-guessed by some school
person I mean it's pretty out what did
absolutely finally and quickly What did
he say about this my dad has been in
shock you he does understand how
something so so like something so small
can turn into something's like why was
my son being interrogated the the school
resource officer hadn't even called my
father about this they didn't even know
was going to meet him yeah they didn't
know this yeah because they they don't
care about his rights as a parent at all